[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show i have to
admit i've i've not really been watching
any of the olympics the other day i was
sitting at an outdoor
bar wearing three masks and two helmets
and i
happened to see a tv which had some
swimming stuff and i watched that a
little bit
but i really just haven't been watching
i think part of it is the time change
makes it so that things are on at kind
of times that aren't convenient for me
but in any case
i did hear that superstar us
gymnast simone biles dropped out of
competition a couple of days ago
too much fanfare not because of a
physical injury
but basically because she didn't feel my
understanding pat is she didn't feel she
was
really performing the way that she
should have she didn't feel mentally
right
to continue and so she dropped out and
incredibly or maybe not many republicans
are just furious and you had people like
charlie kirk and other people on fox
news basically
laughing off the idea that a mental
condition
would keep you out of competition the
way a physical condition would which
shouldn't surprise us because this is a
review on a lot of stuff ptsd
for veterans anxiety you know all these
different things not hugely surprising
and even this now is dividing americans
now i think there's one other part to it
though i will say pat
and it's the same as as the reason why
some republicans are rooting against the
united states women's soccer team in the
olympics
which is that right now um
because joe biden is president the
entire
olympic experience which includes covet
guidelines that are not even joe biden's
their japans
is it's all being put under the umbrella
of a sort of
woke [ __ ] biden related olympic
experience even though it has
essentially nothing to do with joe biden
that's part of why a lot of republicans
are doing this stuff it's crazy that
this is going on
yeah it's also backwards and you know we
know that sports has a huge mental
component so
if simone biles had a mental block and
she didn't think she could perform well
then it
is understandable that she would decide
to pull out we also have to remember she
is a survivor of abuse she was one of
the patients of larry nassar uh um so
you know like
maybe that played a role maybe it didn't
but she decided to bow out and
a lot of conservative commentators were
calling that move selfish yeah also
doesn't make any sense at all because
this is a team sport right so if she
decides not to perform
then another athlete on the team is
going to compete in her place
and simone biles probably assessed that
this other athlete would do better
at the sport than she was given her
current scenario
sure and so that actually is selfless
it's quite the opposite
and uh charlie kirk called her a
sociopath for that i don't think he'd be
able to back that up either
because you know a sociopath is someone
who doesn't have empathy for other
people
i don't see how pulling out of the
competition would suggest that she
doesn't have empathy maybe she doesn't
have empathy for
uh sports fans or people who like
watching gymnastics or something like
that but that's a big stretch
it's bizarre so yeah i mean she for
whatever reason is just like the next
enemy for conservatives and uh i guess
we shouldn't be surprised at this point
right i was gonna say did this surprise
you
and it's weird because when somebody
says are you finding this surprising
with a lot of this stuff
when we see these right wingers go lower
and lower and lower and we say
they've they've gone even lower than we
could have ever imagined i'm not
surprised anymore in the sense that
after the trump era taught me never
overestimate
anything with these people but it still
is shocking that sometimes these things
become big topics like that still shocks
me we're like we're
we're talking about this this is the
topic now that's exactly right it's
shocking but not surprising
yeah some people think are synonymous
terms right but they actually are a
little bit different
we see what they're doing in
conservative media and think whoa that's
crazy why would they be talking about
that
but because they have a pattern of doing
this over the years it's not surprising
because it's not like counter to what
they've done before yeah so those are
two different things there and i do
agree with that assessment do you know
what the republican problem has been
with the u.s women's soccer team
i'm guessing it's something related to
megan rapinoe as a liberal like
does it relate to that somehow megan
rappano is a progressive
and doesn't like trump and probably some
other members of the team also don't
like trump
yeah but they're also like hugely
successful like the women's soccer team
i think have won like half of the
women's world cups
um in the u.s uh the u.s women's soccer
team has won
half of the world cups uh and you know
they always seem to perform well in the
olympics and stuff too
uh so maybe you know it just it doesn't
make any sense like this is rooting
against america
but they don't seem to see it that way
like they're able to pick and choose
which issues they
want to make a point out of sometimes
they're pro police but then you know
when it's
trump is attacking the police officers
then they're no longer in the support of
the police officers so
it's all very strange with republicans i
don't know how they you know
make this logic work for them i i wonder
if part of the soccer thing more broadly
is i'm just thinking out loud here
do they find it emasculating in some way
that the us men's soccer team because
there isn't that there
there's more of a culture of elite
women's soccer in the u.s than elite
men's soccer it's just the reality men's
soccer in the us doesn't have the
culture of brazil
argentina england france italy spa you
know
is there something that conservatives
don't like
about how the uh women's soccer
is so much more powerful globally
than men's soccer is maybe but i think
they just in general
don't like soccer because they don't for
whatever reason see it as a manly sport
maybe because
you don't use your upper body and
there's a lot of running
i don't know what their thought process
is yeah i don't know but you know they
like football
and right i guess to a lesser extent
basketball now because they don't like
how the nba players were protesting yeah
it's all just very strange i don't
really understand their logic
i don't either if somebody if somebody
has an idea let me know a new york city
is going to pay a hundred dollars for
people to get vaccinated against the
coronavirus that starts tomorrow
residents who get their first dose at a
city run site will get a hundred dollar
incentive
bill de blasio announced it yesterday de
blasio says this will make a big impact
he says we want to supercharge it by
saying we'll give you a direct personal
incentive
they will get a hundred dollar prepaid
debit card
and it can be immediately redeemed
digitally or you can get
a physical debit card what do you think
about this
not a bad idea i mean worth trying i
don't think the investment is going to
be all that much right 100
per person many of the people who live
in new york city already have been
vaccinated so you're not even talking
about that many people yeah
and we know that you know the more
people that we vaccinate the more that
we can save on health care costs and the
more the economy can go back to normal
so
it seems like it's a good move uh when
you consider the economy but also just
from a health perspective trying to get
more people vaccinated good all around
i mean maybe it gets a little bit
trickier if you're talking about more
than a hundred dollars
but 100 seems just fine to me mixed in
with this announcement
is one that more people are maybe
reacting to
which is that de blasio announced all
city employees
will need to be fully vaccinated or be
tested regularly by september 16
13 so you're not even actually being
mandated to be vaccinated it's
you have to get vaccinated unless you
want to be getting regularly tested
and bill de blasio fully defending and
in favor of the vaccine mandate
and saying now we're combining mandates
in some places
with a hundred dollar incentive and a
lot of a lot of people are reacting to
that saying here is government mandatory
vaccines and again this is
the city as an employer and you don't
even have to get it it's just get it
if you want to avoid testing yeah i
think de blasio said something to the
effect of the voluntary stage
of the vaccination program is over you
know suggesting that you know we're
going to start having mandates for city
employees and all that stuff
but when right-wingers hear that they go
crazy and they start thinking that this
means that new york city public
officials are going to
go door-to-door and uh jab you forcibly
want to be yeah forcibly or like that's
maybe not what's happening now but
that's the next
thing to come and you know i i
that that there's nothing to suggest
that's going to happen either like we
know that this is going to remain
voluntary
uh if you want a certain job and your
employer
is going to require it of you or if
you're going to work for their city
government and they're going to require
it of you
that's one thing but you also don't have
a right to work at those jobs no
yeah there's a lot of people
fear-mongering and the simple thing to
do is just get vaccinated and i think
you know people are just finding
different reasons to complain about it
no question about it and then meanwhile
by the way to go to our next
story um in florida there are now
at least two mayors that are announcing
mass and vaccine mandates which is a
similar thing to what bill de blasio is
doing in new york
um the republican governor of florida is
ron desantis he's very trumpian
he was like an open it wide open thing
really really early bringing in
i think it was wwe events and ufc events
very early to florida when no other
state was doing
large events like that and there are
a bunch of different ways that ron
desantis has tried to say
no city or municipality can require
masks or require vaccines but mayors
are at least a couple of mayors are
ignoring it miami-dade county will again
be requiring masks
indoors they are in orange county
the mayor went further and said that all
4 200 non-union county employees will
have to get their first vaccine by the
end of august and their second one by
the end of september
disney announced that starting july 30th
masks will be required for everybody 2
and up
and uh while indoors and on the buses
regardless of vaccination status so this
could become a legal fight pat
i believe that the fight will be won by
the mayors and by disney world
uh because ron desantis did not
uh it's not cl ron desantis guidelines
don't appear to
be backed by state or federal law and so
i think that if it does come down to a
fight the mayors who are saying this
will be our policy and the company's
saying this will be our policy i think
they will win
although it could take months to fight
it in court or even longer yeah and i
get the sense that the mayors are doing
this
not necessarily for their own political
interests but really just to watch out
for the people that they represent
because it's this really is not at this
point a good political move to reinstate
mandates and all that stuff especially
because
people are so pandemic weary at this
point we've already been through it for
over a year now and this is probably the
last thing that they want to do but they
know that it can save lives so they're
going to
institute a policy like this but what
ron desantis is doing is just trying to
make it so this is you know a cultural
issue and we're done with the masks and
all this stuff and he's trying to up his
brand because we know that he has
presidential or at least vice
presidential aspirations uh and he
probably wants to get re-elected to as
governor of florida and he also has all
this like national name recognition so
you know he's just posturing i think
whereas these local officials are
actually trying to do what's right for
their people
now let me i completely agree with you
this now i am now coming up against a
bunch of these different guidelines and
changes i think this is a good time as
any dimension that
i'm going to be here hosting next week
monday through thursday
and then friday farron from uh ring of
fire is going to be filling in for me
and then the week after we'll have a
couple different guest hosts farron's
going to be here a little bit
jesse dollamore is going to be here who
i think people
may or may not be familiar with in the
audience but he's really really great
and
and he's agreed to fill in for me a
little bit because i am going to be
traveling
i have some different family and sort of
like teaching
elements going on in spain as i've
mentioned
spain two days ago was just elevated to
a level four do not travel country by
the united states
state department now it is true that
things seem to be going worse in many
other countries that have been left at
level three for example
greece is seeing a major major spike but
they're still level three
so i don't know how much meaning there
is in level three versus level four
at this point in time everything i've
gotten is non-refundable and
i've made the decision that i'm going
pat i'm going and these may be famous
last words now what what will i be doing
well in terms of the flights the flights
i've done before
with the masks and i'm not gonna play
coy with the mask i'm just going to wear
the mask
that's the rule that i'm just going to
be wearing the mask during during the
flight
once there it seems that there is more
masking going on in spain than in the
united states even including outdoors
in certain places if that's what's going
on i will do it i have no problem doing
that i plan on being indoors
very very little in the sense that you
know how in european culture it's all
terraces and patios and this type of
thing so i expect
very very little of what i'm going to be
doing uh to be indoors anyway
i do need a test to come back i've
purchased the test that you
take with you and then you have a video
conference with some with someone who
watches you take the test
and then you get your negative result
and then that's good for the airline i'm
doing
it my sense in talking to different
people is my risk is not dramatically
different than just being in the united
states because i'm going to be doing
similar things
that's what i'm doing and you know
hopefully these aren't famous last words
yeah you're probably fine and you are
fully vaccinated of course sorry to
violate your hipaa rights yes
that's hip-hop vaccinated yep you're
hippo right um
but yeah it sounds like you're taking
the right precautions are you worried
that things could get canceled last
minute though because
uh you know i know that it's just a
recommendation at this point yeah state
department not to travel to spain but
like
do you think that they could all of a
sudden pull the plug and say nope no
americans can travel to europe
except for like very specific reasons
and all of that stuff and i don't think
so
and part of the reason i don't think so
is i am traveling
via so in terms of the flights i'm
traveling via a different country
i'm not going direct to spain so
i assume that my flight to europe
is going to be fine once in europe it no
longer really matters what the us is
saying flights between european
countries are continuing
and then americans are always allowed to
come back to the united states
and i'll have a negative test hopefully
it's negative um so no i don't expect a
situation where i'll get stuck
yeah that's good that americans are
always able to get back to the us
because otherwise we'd have to find
permanent guest hosts and that yeah
that would be tough and jessie
maybe jank and kyle would be interested
in doing it too so there you go just
absolutely
uh yeah let's hope that doesn't happen
but in any case the trip is proceeding
and that's what's going on now
um i i spoke to my brother about this
also my brother's also going to be
traveling
um uh to to visit our family soon
and his thought was you know at this
point
based on when we've all been vaccinated
if indeed immunity starts to wane
after nine or so months this would sort
of be the time to travel unless you're
not going to travel for years because
more than likely
it's going to be little clusters up and
down up and down
for the next year and a half to two
years in other words the point being
if you're not willing to travel now as
someone who's been
only vaccinated six months and you're
probably in the heart of the immunity
you're probably saying you're not going
to travel for years and
hit from his perspective he's like i
think this is basically as good as it's
going to get for at least a couple years
yeah that's a good point but you can
also look at like what the case rates
are in
different countries because there are
peaks and valleys right yeah try to time
it when you're going
uh during a valley where i think uh
right now in spain they're
kind of past another peak so you know
not the best timing but being fully
vaccinated
maybe on the decline yeah so that's
another complexity
that's another complexity which is the
numbers reflect people
infected some period of time before
because
all of the tests for example reported
today
are from results that were obtained
yesterday which are from tests taken in
the one to three days before that
which are on average from people
infected five days before that so in a
way
if we're seeing a decline now that
decline in spain for example
actually started 10 days ago which means
in another 10 days when i get there
it may be a much better situation this
is because there's a delay and there's
incomplete information
i don't know at the end of the day who
the hell knows but when you're planning
travel
you do so months in advance sure
especially if it's travel to a foreign
country so you just can't predict some
of this stuff so without a doubt
uh but i think you'll be just fine and
uh yeah big exciting stuff happening
over the next few weeks here
very very exciting stuff yeah and
hopefully none of it involves any uh
covet infections let's put it uh let's
put it that way
all right uh that's gonna do it for
today we'll be back tomorrow new show
new bonus show i'm here
most of next week so no need to worry
yet
and maybe no need to worry at all we'll
deal with that next